how you manage your sales team close
your sequence is how you manage the
framework call recordings if you're not
recording every single [ __ ] call that
your people are on one you're not
compliant two you should do it because
then they become more accountable to
following the script com you need to
talk to your team on a regular basis the
cadence there is daily huddles weekly
101s when you do the daily huddles all
you do is you share testimonials so they
remember why they're selling from the
101s that you're doing you're going to
have them tag you in three calls their
best call their worst call on their
average call you're going to ask them to
show you where they clarified the
problem and then where they asked for
the sale and where they overcame
objections cut you got to cut the bottom
it has to be on a regular basis
competition last point sales people are
competitive you have to have a
leaderboard that is published that they
can see every single day that they get
notified when every other guy is making
a sale and this is volume they can see
it there's activity there's action right
it's all of momentum to recap if you
want really really consistent sales use
the closer framework everything has to
be questions do not have statements have
30 second stories record your calls make
sure you're sticking to the comp cadence
cut the bottom percentage and keep it
competitive so they stay in it